well guys we have finally made it Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 2 I
have talked about every Harry Potter
movie leading up to fantastic beasts
let's get going with the final one
something about this film that contrasts
very much so with the others is how
fast-paced this movie is right from the
get-go you feel like you're just it it's
instantly going and you better get on
this ride or it's gonna leave you behind
it is one of the shorter Harry Potter's
so that definitely has something to do
with it as well but it's also a Harry
Potter film that doesn't have to set up
anything else everything comes to a halt
in this movie everything ends in this
film and so there's no need to build up
various arcs this movie is where
everything explodes and from beginning
to end this film is a non-stop ride of
intense drama and action really
heartfelt character moments and all of
these things you've been waiting to see
forever finally happening every Potter
so we pick up with our three heroes
still looking for the remaining Horcrux
is to get them to hopefully kill
Voldemort once and for all they have to
infiltrate the caves and Griphook a
little slimy dick helps them for a while
ass and here we get a really fun
underground cave sequence where we meet
the dragon and this thing is so
beautiful I love this creature it's one
of my favorite creatures in all the
Harry Potter world and they ride this
dragon to safety and then plummet down
into the water and then we get a cool
fanfiction a moment where everyone takes
off their clothes oh I might put that in
maybe I want no fuck it I'm putting that
in here they meet up with Neville who
leads them underground to Hogwarts so
nice to be back in Hogwarts this school
wasn't in part one and it feels like
you're returning to this place of
comfort despite how dark it is and
despite how everyone is like oh no
everything shitty
but what's really affirming in this
movie is you finally see everyone look
at Harry Potter and go like you were
right all along we're with you let's do
this thing man the faculty and the
students they're all just together on
this and you feel like you are about to
witness something truly epic and later
when Snape is interrogating the students
trying to figure out what Harry Potter
is Harry's it's like hey screw it Here I
am I'm right here yeah deal with it
Harry's done hiding this is the movie
where he truly steps into the role of
the leader he did that in other films
like order of the Phoenix when he helps
teach the kids but in this film it's
truly when he's like you know what let's
do this
now when it comes to satisfying moments
in movies moments of true catharsis I
think of Spider Man 2 and the way that
film ended with MJ and Peter I think of
the final shot of Return of the Jedi
with all of our heroes together and I
think of McGonagall fighting Snape and
then banishing Slytherin to the dungeon
so much pleasurable happiness comes from
this moment and Maggie Smith is just
like the most adorable grandma of all
time when she's like I always wanted to
do that and what's really special about
this film compared to the others is how
urgent everything feels there's a level
of stakes here that makes everything
feel very in the moment everything feels
like we are in this right now and this
is when the big attack begins Voldemort
and his forces against Hogwarts this is
where everything comes to a head and
this is where the film gets even better
Ron and Hermione are able to destroy one
of the Horcruxes with the basilisk Fang
Voldemort inist forces eventually take
down the shield surrounding Hogwarts
Draco and his dumb idiot friends burned
down the Room of Requirement I mean in
one final last act of idiocy these
people have to do something dumb can
they just be normal for one movie can
they just be like okay can at least be
semi okay for one film no they got to be
dicks to the last minute and man I
thought Dobby dying was hard now I have
to watch possibly my favorite character
and all the Harry Potter films die
Snape's death though is handled really
well it's it's heartbreaking I mean it's
just there's a bit of an info dump
though with this scene where you learn
about Snape's past and how he loved Lily
Potter this is much needed though it
really tells you a lot about his
character and when you rewatch all
of the other films with this knowledge
everything just feels so much more in
focus now and Snape is even more of a
heartbreaking character after you learn
this now Harry goes off into the forest
to challenge Voldemort alone we get a
beautiful scene involving his parents
and Voldemort kills Harry Potter but I
loved the following scene with
Dumbledore and Harry in limbo where
Harry learned some things about himself
the fact that he had to die for this to
happen
Harry Potter's body is brought back to
Hogwarts and Neville makes the most
inspiring heartfelt awesome speech you
could possibly imagine Harry Potter's
just like my back you sons of bitches
you're going down yes everything is so
satisfying right now so much is just
coming to fruition and this is where
Harry Potter and Voldemort finally have
their epic showdown and Voldemort dies
he just melts away and turns to ash and
you just like so long sucker
as Harry is walking through Hogwarts and
he sees everybody picking themselves up
he looks at all these characters all
these people he's known for so long you
get this amazing sense of euphoria it
just feels so right and the ending of
this film showing Harry and Hermione and
Ron grown up with kids of their own
sending them off to Hogwarts it could
not have ended better in a more
satisfying way for fans and I gotta say
they did it they did it they made the
very last Harry Potter the best one this
is my favorite in the entire franchise
and not just because you get all the big
action II stuff this entire film feels
so urgent as I said the stakes feel so
real and everything just comes to a head
so beautifully it's such an entertaining
and well made movie Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 2 gets an A+
guys I am done talking about the Harry
Potter films I had such a great time
talking you guys about these movies this
year I'm looking forward to fantastic
beasts thank you very much for watching
this series every single review is going
to be shown to you in a minute in a
playlist form if you haven't seen them
you can click on it and check them out
thanks so much for watching guys I
solemnly swear that I am up to no good
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you